avant tout j'aimerais peut-être vous
jouez une bande vidéo du déroulement des
événements d'hier et ensuite je vais
passer à d'autres explications
je veux dire deux jours ci avait aussi
la scène à l'entrée du parlement sur la
rue elgin vous voyez des individus qui
semblent se replier vers l'ouest et en
lien avec les événements au cénotaphe
vous verrez un véhicule qui s'approche
le suspect armé qui courent et qui monte
vers le parlement vers l'édifice de
l'est
voici une autre vue de la même scène
prise l'autre angle
eh bien on devait déjà nouveau
l'individu semblait il ya des individus
qui semblait se replier en lien avec les
événements ça nataf
sem angels encore une fois une autre
prise de vue de la même entrée vers
l'enceinte parlementaire
ce qu'on aime qui s'écrasait le projet
sert que c'est le to qui s'approche un
des piétons s'approche de l'auto sas et
mesure que le suspect sort avec son arme
à feu légende et al et maintenant vous
verrez ici vers l'édifice tu de l'est il
court vers les véhicules qui sont
stationnés le premier de la file ces
véhicules d'un ministre le suspect fait
le tour pas en avant il y à un échange
avec le chauffeur de ce véhicule
ministériel il recule un peu le véhicule
le chauffeur sort et part en courant
suspect se dirige vers l'édifice du
centre
c'est à ce moment c'est que ces gestes
ont été remarqués par les constables a
géré c'est le véhicule qui s'avance avec
la portière ouverte et en poursuite du
véhicule
vous voyez l'autobus vers hesdin et là
il y a une autre auto patrouille l'a
géré sic qui s'en approche ils ont vu
vous verrez le suspect entrer dans
l'édifice du centre ville nous constable
sont derrière lui à le poursuivre et à
mesure qu'ils arrivent près de la porte
et il y à un échange de coups de feu
à mesure que les responsables de la
sécurité parlementaire sur nos consoles
reculent quelques moments est ensuite
parti à ses trousses il là ils y voient
là une autre vue de ce véhicule
ministériel qui s'approche de l'édifice
du centre
voilà le suspect qui entre en courant
dans l'édifice du centre
voyez vous voyez les policiers qui sont
à ses trousses et qui se dirigent aussi
vers cette entrée de lévis du édifice du
centre sous la tour de la paix sur la
colline parlementaire